caroline mécary avocate au barreau
paille bonjour tyrolien de macquarie
merci de répondre à nos questions
comment est-ce que vous accueillez cette
décision elle vous surprend bien est-ce
que vous vous attendiez à ce que ce
recours se racheter écoutez elle est
vraiment consternant c'est à dire qu'en
fait le conseil d'état et l'auxiliaire
des carences de l'état quand on lit la
décision on constate qu'ils l'expliquent
par le fait que l'état n'est pas en
mesure de fournir des masques à tout le
monde alors d'un côté l'état dit je vais
fournir des masques aux magistrats et
greffiers qui sont dans les audiences
et dans le même temps il reconnaît que
les avocats sont des auxiliaires de
justice qu'ils participent à ce
processus judiciaire dans les audiences
mais eux ils doivent se débrouiller
cette décision est vraiment content
traître est consternante le conseil
n'est pas ce film qu'il n'y a pas de
carence portant une atteinte grave et
manifestement illégale à la liberté
fondamentale
vous êtes d'accord elle ce postulat bien
sûr que non il est évident que le
conseil d'état aujourd'hui n'est plus le
contre-pouvoir que l'on pouvait attendre
de sa part
je rappelle qu'il a un pouvoir de
contrôle sur les gouvernements
successifs et qu'en réalité il ne permet
pas de protéger les avocats dans leur
mission de d'auxiliaires de justice dans
le cadre de l'exercice de la justice
lorsqu'un avocat 20 en garde à vue les
policiers portent des masques
il est devrait être normal que les
avocats puissent bénéficier de la même
protection dès lors que l'assistance
d'un d'une personne en garde à vue et
qu'une mission de service public
il en est de même lorsque nous allons
dans les tribunaux pour assister les
clients en comparution immédiate ou bien
pour des demandes de mise en liberté
les magistrats ont des masques les
greffiers ont des masques il participe
au service public de la justice tout
comme les avocats et les avocats ne
devrait pas être protégé ceci n'est pas
normal très clairement
malgré tout la juridiction estime que
l'état doit aider les avocats à se
procurer du matériel de protection
en facilitant l accès des barreaux
circuits d'approvisionnement
l état est tout de même mis devant ses
responsabilités non oui non
voyez bien non parce que d'abord un les
recours ont été rejetés c'est le sens de
l' ordonnance qui a été rendu hier et
vous voyez bien en réalité que le
conseil d'état sait pertinemment que le
port du masque et la possibilité d'avoir
accès à des ja du gel qui permet de
nettoyer les mains est quelque chose de
très important
donc il dit il faut faciliter le fait
que les avocats puissent avoir accès à
ces éléments mais il ne
non joint pas à l'état de mettre à
disposition ses éléments pour les
avocats qui sont des auxiliaires de
justice
dans ce cadre là en réalité le conseil
d'état ne va pas jusqu'au bout de la
logique et finalement il n'est que
j'allais dire le juge de la pénurie le
droit aujourd'hui pour le conseil d'état
ce n'est pas le droit c'est en réalité
la gestion de la pénurie matériel des
masques et du gel on l'a vu ces derniers
jours
le conseil d'état a rejeté plusieurs
recours liés à l'épidémie celui
d'associations d'aidé aux sans abri
celui d'une association qui défend les
droits des détenus celui de 210,4
soignants etc
comment est-ce que vous analysez ces
rejets multiples du bien il ya deux
éléments en fait très clairement le
conseil d'état est devenu l'auxiliaire
de la police administrative décidée par
le gouvernement
et deuxièmement c'est la conséquence
c'est que le conseil d'état n'est plus
un contre pouvoir et que la justice et
des libertés fondamentales sont
aujourd'hui mises en quarantaine par
l'état d'urgence sanitaire que le
conseil d'état valide à tous égards en
tant qu'avocate quelques cars entiers
attendez vous du déconfinement
progressif qui doit débuter le 11 mai
est ce que vous estimez que les
conditions sont réunies pour que vous
repreniez l'activité professionnelle
alors pour le moment en fait personne
n'en sait rien très clairement et la
porte parole du gouvernement l'a dit
très clairement elle même et le
gouvernement ne savent pas comment ils
vont préparer le déconfinement j'ai
entendu juste avant moi
le ministre blanc caire parler de la
rentrée des élèves à l'école réellement
c'était pathétique
on voit bien que
il y à un amateurisme et une
impréparation qui sont extrêmement
importantes
les avocats prendront leurs
responsabilités c'est à dire que il pas
lire ou certainement les carences de
l'état qui n'a été enfin qu' en tout cas
pour l'exercice professionnel n'a été
d'aucun secours je rappelle que
aujourd'hui 4 l'activité judiciaire est
arrêté à 95 % ce qui par ailleurs place
les cabinets d'avocats dans des
situations extrêmement difficile
extrêmement délicate
merci caroline mécary d'abord répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
avocate au barreau de paris